There are other points above this line that represent saving more than $100 per
month. For example, after 1 month, I could have also saved $400 or after 1 month
I could have also saved $450 or even $500. Similar reasoning could be used at 2
months, I could have saved maybe $600. Or 700, so there's tons of points farther
above this region. Because all these y values are the amount of money saved
falls above this line, we can change our equation into an inequality. We want
our savings amount to be greater than the exact amount of $200 plus the $100 per
month. So this is the inequality we can write. Notice that linear inequalities
contain 2 variables, just like linear equations. This allows us to find a point,
x and y, that satisfies this condition. For example I can use this point and
plug in 2 for x and 500 for y and I should get a true statement. And when I do,
I get 500 is greater than 400, so yes this is true. Also remember from before,
we said that one 300 couldn't be a point for our inequality. We didn't save more
than $100 per month. So I need some way to represent that on the line. I can't
actually include the points on the line, so I'm going to use a dashed line to
exclude them. We know any of the points above this line satisfy our inequality.
This shaded reason up above would represent every instance when we saved more
than $100 in a month. Let's say you allowed yourself to save exactly $100 or
more per month. So now we could be greater than or equal to. Well, this point
can now be a point on our line. If you allow yourself to save exactly $100 or
more in a month then now we can include this point in our inequality. We can see
that by plugging it in we get a true statement. 300 is greater than or equal to
300. I need to change my graph to reflect that so, instead of using a dash line
I'll use a solid one. That will represent the equal to part. When graphing
linear inequalities, we use a solid line for greater than or equal to, and less
than or equal to. If we see the greater than or the less than sign, then we use
a dashed line.